say his name say his name
people gather to remember george floyd
who went out for a packet of cigarettes
just under a year ago
and ended up dead at the hands or knee
of a white police officer george floyd
should not go down in history it's just
someone with a knee on his neck
george floyd should go down his history
that broke the neck
of black of police racism
police brutality and police
illegality i will stand and be the voice
for him
i will stand and be the change for him
i will stand and continue to be the
legacy for him
find the defendant guilty derek chauvin
has been found guilty of
murder and manslaughter and will be
sentenced on the 25th
of next month you cannot separate
justice
from peace but the debate continues to
rage as to whether meaningful police
reform
is taking place how can they reform
something
without including us you can't reform
anything if you don't include the people
who are
directly affected by it we're going to
go up a mountain
but we finally got to the base of the
mountain we've been journeying to the
base now we're at the base of the
mountain but there's
still a mountain to climb
after the rally is over those
remembering george floyd reclaimed some
streets of downtown minneapolis
the number significantly smaller than
the tens of thousands who marched here
in the months after the murder police
reform legislation remained stuck
in congress president biden had asked
for it to be placed on his desk
by the day of the anniversary on tuesday
but then the floyd family will visit the
white house
but there will be no new laws on the
desk
mike henna al jazeera minneapolis